[موسيقى]
بصراحه سيكون عار على الغرب اذا ما عاد
الى المحادثات النوويه هؤلاء هنا النساء
المطاطي الذي اطلق عليهم بسبب تظاهر
السلمي النساء التاريخ
[موسيقى]
في هذه اللحظه بالذات على المجتمع الدولي
ان يفرض اكبر كميه من الضغط على النظام
الايراني
مع العنف انت محققه العنف هو احدى ادوات
هذا النظام لكن هل تعرفين لماذا يستخدمونه
باستمرار لانهم يفلتون من العقاب لانهم
يتمتعون بالحصانه يجب ان نضع حدا لحصانه
ايران ودول اخرى وهذا يتم من خلال جمعنا
للادله حول الانتهاكات التي يقوم بها
النظام الان بشكل يومي
[موسيقى]
طب انا اقول باننا نتفاعل مع القدر
العالميين فهذا لا يعني ابدا باننا نقصد
قاده الغرب فقط هذه على الاقل ليست نيتي
واعرف بانه ليست 100 مسيح ايضا ترد ايران
من المفوضيه الامم المتحده حول وضع المراه
خطوه غير مسلوقه
[موسيقى]